eh bien nous sommes en direct de la
canicule merveilleuse journée pour aller
se faire cramer la peau des fesses donc
c'est la journée que j'ai choisi pour ma
17e séances de laser
je suis outrageusement bronzer parce que
je reviens du hellfest et qu'il a fait
déjà très très chaud je file et comme
d'habitude si dieu me prête vie je
reviens vous garantit des griffures
[Musique]
extrêmement chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bruit blanc fruits
mais voilà alors je suis terrée dans le
noir est malgré tout je suis en âge pas
possible parce que c'est la canicule
vous n'êtes pas sans le savoir
accessoirement je voudrais être
transparents et vous je vous dois la
vérité j'ai un peu fait la fête hier
soir et j'ai très peu dormi
voilà parce que c'était mon anniversaire
[Musique]
on avait déjà parlé dans une vidéo il ya
très longtemps mais le mélange pas
beaucoup dormi plus c'est la fête par
fait la fête on se comprend
ben c'est déconseillé avant une séance
de laser sais pas c'est pas top mais en
moins 7 cette séance s'est très très
bien passé
un petit peu plus tard dans la vidéo je
reviendrai sur une petite précision
parce que j'ai peur de vous avoir un
peut induire en erreur dans les aidant
les dernières vidéos
mais avant tout comme je voulais dit je
reviens du jeu revient du hellfest
onze agents témoigné l'état demeure fois
également j'ai encore eu le bonheur et
le plaisir de discuter que beaucoup
d'entre vous et vous avez encore une
fois évidemment gérer je ne m'en plains
pas je savais à quoi m'attendre
vous avez été très nombreuses et très
nombreux à me parler de cyril voilà bien
sûr évidemment mais vous avez surtout
été très nombreux des très nombreux à me
poser plein de questions auxquelles j'ai
déjà répondu j'ai pour je vais me
permettre cette voie là de vous remettre
quelque part par là je ne sais pas où le
lien vers la faq dans laquelle je
réponds à toutes ces questions que vous
continuez imposer voilà comme ça je peux
être qu'à force ça va finir par rentrer
bon ceci étant dit pas séance du jour
comme vous l'avez vu en termes de
douleur maintenant on sait à quoi
s'attendre pas de pas de soucie pas de
surprise tout va bien mêmes réglages que
les dernières fois c'était dur
d'un malaise on tabasse quoi de
particules est barrée en particulier le
médecin et voilà toujours confiant
toujours conscient aussi du fait que oui
ça prend un petit peu de temps il est
une personne extrêmement flegmatique
extrêmement sympathique il a manifesté
un nom pas de l'agacement mais bon il
sait dire
il commence un peu à me à m'agacer c'est
cyril hanouna alors pas le vrai le beau
sûrement que si également mettre ses
marques dans sa toile je dis oui
vraiment il y met du temps à il met du
temps à partir à marquer donc voilà donc
toujours aussi toujours c'est sympa
toujours aussi confiant donc on continue
on continue comme ça là comme une grosse
gros réglages grosse puissance
je laisse tout ça au repos pendant deux
mois ce qui est pas mal comme ça ça mais
c'est l'été j'avais dire aux frais mais
non sans doute au chaud mais elle était
tranquille et je reprends je reprends
tout ça à la rentrée ce que je voulais
vous dire je vous ai parlé dans les deux
dernières vidéos je crois 2
une histoire de mettre ma fesse au
soleil pour que le soleil fasse aussi un
peu lui sont son travail de sabres ont
ça des bronzes et ça fait passer le
reste de tatouages attention là on ne
parle pas de cet été on ne parle pas de
cet été parce que le conseil le conseil
le soleil c'est déconseillé en période
de traitement au laser
c'est à dire que un mois avant il faut
éviter d'avoir exposé la zone au soleil
et minimum un mois voire deux mois après
il faut pas non plus exposé le la zone
qui a été boudé tatoué au soleil donc
vous avez fait le calcul même minimum un
mois avant un mois après ça fait de moi
vu que j'y retourne en deux mois de
toute façon c'est hors de question
éventuellement exposer cette zone au
soleil une fois que tout sera terminé et
que je n'aurai plus de séances de laser
de prévu mais qui restera quand même un
petit peu de pigments bon pour finir de
faire tout tout dégager ok mais nous
disons un mois deux mois
facile après la fin des séances de laser
donc pas cet été donc ça à résoudre mon
problème je n'achète pas de stream pour
cet été je cache cet objet conclu en
l'occurrence sous une couche public de
textile là ça me paraissait important de
revenir là dessus donc un mois avant un
ou deux mois avant un ou deux mois après
une séance de laser pas de soleil donc
en gros pendant toute la période du
traitement pas de soleil pour moi c'est
pas trop un souci plus l'emplacement
si vous êtes dans le même cas que master
qui vous êtes en plein traitement laser
pour un détatouage pensez-y protéger
la zone voilà autre petite précision si
par hasard vous prenez des médicaments
photosensibilisants photo la lumière
sensibilisant qui rend sensible a donc
qui vous prenez des médicaments qui
rendent sensibles à la lumière en
l'occurrence la la le laser celle de la
lumière
le médecin qui vous suit a dû vous en
parler normalement mais il faut les
arrêter au moins 48 heures avant la
séance de laser poser la question aux
médecins surtout si vous faites un
détatouage n'oubliez pas de préciser aux
médecins si vous avez un traitement en
cours
dites-lui lui sera vous dire s'il faut
l'arrêter avant pas sais pas je vais pas
faire ça la place des professionnels
mes pensées pensez bien à en parler au
médecin si c'est votre cas donc
maintenant voici venu le moment du riz
ville donc voilà la photo du tatouage
avant la dernière séance
c'est à dire deux mois maintenant voilà
à quoi ça ressemblait et voilà la photo
ce matin juste avant la séance
voilà à quoi ça ressemblait donc ça
continue à s'estomper il reste des
endroits où manifestement bonne bonne
couche de d'encre parce que c'est il
reste dressent des traits un peu
ballesta je vous ai remis cette fois
quand même une petite photo juste après
la séance pour que vous voyez un petit
peu à quoi ça ressemble c'est assez
marrant de constater que une fois que la
fameuse petite pellicule blanche qui
parfois donne l'impression que l'encré
partie complètement qui en fait est
juste une réaction décollement de la
peau qui cache un petit peu tout ça une
fois tout ça c'est un peu aplatie
finalement le l'encré elle ressort un
peu plus qu'avant la séance voyait là ya
des endroits où on a l'impression que
c'est encore plus foncée qu'avant la
séance bah c'est juste que ça a éclaté
tout ça ça va être ça va être éliminé
gens qui m'ont pas par mon organisme est
donc je donne rendez-vous dans deux mois
pour voir à quoi ça ressemble et si ça
et si ça continue à faire son petit
bonhomme de chemin et pas comme je les
dis à tous ceux et toutes celles qui
m'ont posé la question je suis assez
satisfait de duke
de la progression là sur les quelques
dernières séances c'est celle ont un
passé long depuis le début maintenant
mais on en voit là on en voit le bout
donc donc c'est plutôt pas mal
qu'est ce qui va se passer pendant cet
été parce qu'après tout vous ne savez
pas eh ben les vidéos continue on a une
tous les 15 jours parce que on a tout
autre chose à faire que de regarder des
vidéos et dont tournai ah non tu auras
une vidéo tous les quinze jours
je ne vous abandonne pas on se retrouve
à la rentrée
moi avec mon laser et toutes mes autres
toutes mes autres vidéos je vous
souhaite de très bonnes vacances
si vous en prenez si vous n'en prenez
pas je vous souhaite un très bel été
parce qu'on peut profiter profiter de
l'été même si on n'a pas de vacances et
surtout la mettez vous bien et portez
vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]